hey guys this is jackson wang and this
is the
what wide auto complete
[Music]
do i google myself uh sometimes
i google myself just to see
what's up with me on the internet
what jackson wang what is jackson wang
the ceo of
team wang we started with you know two
men
like me and a manager and then we built
from
two to over 60 70
employees now okay second what languages
did jackson wang
speak i speak a lot of different
languages but i'm not
pro i'm not pro pro pro at it i speak
english i
speak mandarin i speak cantonese i speak
shanghainese and i speak korean what is
jackson wang's job
performer entertainer singer
i'm just jackson wang yeah what is
jackson wearing 100 ways about
there's a hundred ways to leave a lover
but i'm the only one that you need
so it means like exactly what i just
said
okay next who is jackson wang's best
friend
i don't want any of my friends to feel
bad you know i don't want them to you
know to text me in the middle of a night
and and
say hey i saw that interview bro it
hurts
so i'm not answering this next
who is jackson one's brother his name is
winston he lives in australia now
married
with ruby has a daughter amy they're
living a happy life and that's it
okay who is jackson when crush
my fans
who is jackson when married to hey
absolutely no one
no one at the moment maybe when i'm like
35 i don't know 40
45 that's like a future conversation but
at the moment stop
next okay can jackson wang cook who
would
search that who would search
ken jackson went cook i can it's just
that i haven't been
showing a lot of my cooking side
but i can i can cook scrambled eggs
make you a sandwich whoever come up with
this
don't worry can jackson went drive yes i
can
i have a driver license in korea and
uh international license i can if you're
talking about like tokyo drift level i
can't
but normally as a normal human being i
can't i can drive
okay next can jackson one play piano uh
yes i can but it's i'm not good
i can different chords yes i can
okay ken jackson went sing hey that's
pretty offensive
whoever
i'm trying my best why jackson wang
let's get into that category uh why
can't jackson wang speak english
because i went to international school
yeah
american international school why is
jackson when called
sunny because my korean name
is jackson so uh my korean fans instead
of calling me jackson
they call me sun but in korea if you
cause somebody
there's actually uh you know it has to
do with the grandma stuff okay it has to
do with some grammar
technical uh grandma grandma problem
i don't know how to explain this okay
apparently they just call me cinny
okay how jackson wang how tall is
jackson wang feet
how tall is my feet or are you asking me
how tall
in terms of feet whoever that's
uh searching this
[Music]
thank you how did jackson went and
learned korean uh i studied
for a year yeah studied
and i dared to make mistakes i'm not
embarrassed
next how jackson went learn english
that was a question before
if you would just go back and
i mentioned it already how did jackson
went lose weight i went on a diet
eating a lot of vegetables you know
going to the gym doing some cardio
my gym routine is jog for like 30 40
minutes
incline and lift some weights
eat a lot of vegetables a lot of fruits
cut down on some carbs
a little bit don't eat at midnight and
sleep a lot
okay how did jackson one learn to sing i
took lessons in
jyp when i was a trainee okay uh
does jackson wang act not yet
i will if you know maybe in the future
i'm very into action films
fighting scenes yeah does jackson went
have tattoos
next does jackson wang have a dog no
but i would like to when i feel like
i really really can be responsible
does jackson wang write his own songs uh
yes i do
from time to time you know some songs i
co-produced
with other people just in terms of
production
i always co-produ co-produce with a lot
of different people does jackson wang
reply on instagram
oh i don't know i think you should go
leave a comment before that i think you
should go
follow jacksonwing on instagram and then
leave a comment
in one of this post and see if he
replies
next is jackson wang a solo artist yes
i am yes i am fact
yep next is jackson wang a ceo
i don't know if you call a ceo because
ceo
gets really deep deep deep in operation
but i'm more of like a person that runs
the company
and monitor every almost everything
whatever you call it it's just a title
it's not that important
it's jackson wang rapper hey whatever
like i said
i'm i'm a performer i'm an artist i'm an
entertainer i'm this i'm a
whatever you call it okay is jackson
wearing a k-pop idol
i i go back go back
to that previous question is jackson
when an olympian yes
i went to youth olympic 2010 the first
youth olympic in singapore
next is jackson wang left-handed who
would search
that no i'm right-handed as jackson went
allergic to spicy food yes i am
i haven't been checked yet but i think
i'm very allergic to
spicy food because if i eat spicy food
my face gets swollen i sweat a lot
but only my head as jackson went
allergic to cats i love
cats but i don't i don't know from since
when
i started to be allergic to cats you
know my eyes would itch
i would get rashes yeah jackson wang
age 1994 march 28
aries the year of dog
jackson wang asynthetic
next jackson wang vocal range
hey i don't think i have the need
to tell you my vocal range
jackson wing diet yes i'm always on a
diet i think
being in in a fit condition
is also you know a big part of the
product
i present to the audience to my fans to
to everyone last card i hope nothing
crazy comes out okay
uh jackson wang motivational quotes
know yourself make your own history
okay next jackson one favorite color
[Music]
i don't really have one jackson wearing
new song yes
my latest single it's called leave me
loving you
and it's a love song love story it's
also
a continuous story from my last release
called pretty please as you can see for
the music video
it's basically in the same outfit it's
the identical
uh character just promoted my song right
here
jackson wang nicknames sunni
wang puppy starbury p jack
a lot thank you for all the questions i
answer all of them
and i hope you enjoy the video and i
take care of yourself i love you guys so
much and it's a wrap
for um wired auto